when it comes to spider-man in the MCU
and the fans Marvel seems to be looking
out for us and listening to us and
trying to give us what we want with
spider-man how's it going everybody it's
Warren and earlier this year we had a
scare with spider-man exiting the MCU
luckily for us Marvel Studios and Disney
worked out a deal with Sony to have
spider-man remain in the MCU and not
only is he remaining in the MCU but
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios hinted that he could appear in
venom 2 he stated he also happens to be
the only hero with the super power to
cross cinematic universes so as Sony
continues to develop their own Spidey
verse you never know what surprises the
future might hold and again that came
directly from Kevin Feige and today we
have a new report that says that Sony is
in talks to have spider-man appear in
venom 2 so let's break down this report
but first don't forget to subscribe but
when notifications turned on and click
the link in the description down below
there's only three days left in my
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway so again
according to reports Tom Holland is and
talks with Sony for a Spider Man cameo
in venom 2 this report comes from Daniel
R P K's patreon account many of you may
know Daniel he's been right about a lot
of leaks in the MCU the most recent one
being when the Black Widow trailer was
going to drop I'll link his YouTube page
and his patreon down below if you want
to follow him for some inside scoops but
he's the one saying that Sony is in
talks with Tom Holland so it seems like
something that everybody is really
wanted for a long time
spider-man and venom 2 could be
happening however this doesn't
necessarily mean that venom is going to
exist in the MCU as the report is for
spider-man 2 cameo in venom 2 which is
in a different universe however it was
reported by deadline after the Disney
Sony deal was settled for spider-man
remaining in the MCU part of the deal
according to Deadline was for Sony to be
able to reference MCU characters in
their venom films so even though if
spider-man cameos in venom 2 it
technically won't exist in the MCU it
still opens up the venom verse for
spider-man to appear in future films and
this isn't the only report we've gotten
lately that says that spider-man made
cameo in venom 2 yesterday the geeks
worldwide reported a casting breakdown
for venom two that had spider-man on it
however their report says that even
though Tom Hall
spider-man may appear in venom too it
may not be the same spider-man from the
MCU this would of course be done so the
Sony verse and the MCU could be separate
Sony already wanted Tom Hollands
spider-man to cameo in venom one but
Marvel said no because they didn't want
people to be confused and think that
venom is a part of the MCU so Marvel
probably still has this concern so in
order to make it to where people don't
get too confused they may have Tom
Hollands spider-man simply be from a
different universe and have no
connection to the MCU whatsoever however
this may be even more confusing having
two different versions of spider-man
played by the same actor could confuse
people
but since phase four is going to be huge
in introducing the multiverse into the
MCU it may just work there's going to be
a bunch of different versions of
characters that we're going to see in
different universes so the MCU could
simply state that the venom verse is
just another one of these alternate
realities different universes there's
lots of ways around it that could make
sense but considering the fact that
phase 4 and specifically Doctor Strange
and the multiverse of madness is going
to explore the multiverse it would make
sense that this Spider Man that would
appear in venom 2 is simply an alternate
version of spider-man from a different
universe but either way according to
multiple reports Tom Holland is in talks
with Sony for a Spider Man cameo in
venom 2 would you prefer Spider Man to
be from the MCU or would you prefer an
alternate universe version of spider-man
to appear in venom - be sure to comment
down below and let me know what you
think also don't forget to like the
video and subscribe but with
notifications turned on so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or ps4 the winner gets to choose and
I'm picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers and again
only three days left in the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway so don't forget to
click the link in the description down
below
use code cosmic @ G feel calm for a
discount on your G fill and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof